The Invisible Man was a fairly popular
movie before quarantine I wonder why
this episode of things you missed is
struggling people are watching the
ratings are good I wonder what could be
the issue let's look at the comments
pretty sure screen rent ripped this off
practically word for word yeah
that's an issue on February 27th 2020 I
uploaded a new episode of my
long-running web series things you met a
show where I analyze the often
overlooked details of your favorite
horror movies when my video started to
get popular in 2017 I noticed a lot of
imitators which is understandable
chasing trends is pretty common in this
era of YouTube and it makes sense that
other youtubers might have their own
interpretations of horror films and I
wouldn't really be bothered if another
creator came to a similar conclusion
about what a director intended with his
or her movie from time to time it only
makes sense so I usually ignore these
knockoff videos when I see them then I
saw this comment practically
word-for-word that got my attention on
March 6 over a week after I published my
video screen ran a massive company with
over seven million subscribers compared
to my 350 thousand at the time puts out
25 things you missed in the Invisible
Man usually when I see these knockoff
videos they at least change the title up
a little bit like they'll say small
details you missed or things you didn't
notice but Screen Rant decided to
straight-up steal my title not the end
of the world
let's compare to the actual videos
here's the clip from my video Adrian's
full name by the way is Adrian Griffin
which is a slight nod to Jack Griffin
the scientist who learned how to make
himself invisible and became the
original Invisible Man and here's the
screen rant video but this isn't the
first time we've seen a disappearing man
with the last name Griffin way back in
the 1933 version of the Invisible Man
we saw the character Jack Griffin played
by Claude Rains okay we can give them
the benefit of the doubt here I mean
we're both basically citing publicly
available knowledge
Cecilia's name on the other hand is a
feminine version of the name cecil which
is derived from the latin word meaning
blind seeing as how she can't see adrian
the name cecilia is actually a feminine
form of the names to silk which comes
from the Roman name cos Silius this name
is based on the latin word caucus which
translates to blind obviously the fact
that Moss's character's name means blind
is meaningful here since she's haunted
by an enemy who was invisible to her I
don't even think it's that crazy to
bring this up because I
is Leigh Whannell intention to put
meaning behind the character names I
mean I'm not the only one who's allowed
to notice it but using the exact same
image I used and breaking down the words
history exactly as I did is kind of
suspicious and it is almost
word-for-word it's like the classic
school report where you just have to
change the wording so that it doesn't
look like it's copy and pasted from
Wikipedia but it's a huge company in a
four-story building ripping off an
independent youtuber during a global
recession when Cecilia is escaping we
see her Cal Poly architecture sweater
and later she interviews for a job at an
architectural firm the characters have
fitting career choices for their roles
in the story architecture represents
privacy it's the idea of putting up
walls and shielding yourself from the
gaze of the outside world an optics
technology represents the invasion of
privacy people like Adrian are suppliers
for paparazzi and in our world today
technology companies are seen as leashes
for data and are often criticized for
their misleading privacy policies when
she's trying to escape we see that she's
wearing a top with the logo of Cal Poly
architecture this College of
Architecture and Environmental Design is
a real place and apparently Cecilia was
a student at some point since we saw her
during an interview for an architectural
firm Architects are quite literally
responsible for putting up walls which
seems fitting since the Celia spends
most of the movie desperately trying to
shield herself from Adrian it also
provides a contrast with his occupation
as a scientist in the field of optics
while she's trying to keep people out
he's trying to find a way in okay so not
only have they just taken my personal
interpretation and claimed it as their
own but they've laid it out in the exact
same way not even bothering to change
most of my phrasing or my presentation
style like it's very clear that they
just watched my video and somehow liked
how I start with the visual of the
sweater to segue into talking about
their career choices and they basically
just said you know what that's ours now
after Cecilia escaped she's staying at
James's house and I noticed him wearing
a shirt that says prestige records 1949
the year may be a reference to the
release day of the Invisible Man appears
which was a Japanese adaptation of HG
Wells novel The Invisible Man which is
what the original film was based on
James's home is a welcome refuge from
Adrian but pay attention to the shirt
he's wearing it says prestige records
1949 1949 was the year the movie
ptomaine ninja gnar
war room was released in Japan a movie
also known as invisible man appears it's
not apt ation of the HG Wells book The
Invisible Man it's also a Japanese
restaurant where Cecilia and Emilie
later have the reconciliation meeting
though that may be a coincidence hard to
say for sure is this just a coincidence
or is it an easter egg that requires a
lot of invisible man knowledge to spot
well I'll tell you what's not a
coincidence you somehow coming out with
a video that's nearly identical to my
video in almost every way how is it that
you have a 17 man team not including any
of the resources from your parent
company who's hiring for 19 different
types of positions and the best you can
do is a blatant to plagiarize ation of a
guy with a camera Cecilia's sleeping in
the same room as the daughter Sydney and
her dream is to go to fashion school so
her room is filled with clothing of her
own design as you might expect there's a
mannequin in the room and it's wearing
this one has this is a big Easter egg
because the mannequin is basically
dressed up like the Invisible Man from
the original movie James's daughter
Sydney dreams of going to fashion school
so understandably her bedroom is filled
with everything an aspiring fashion
designer might need this includes a
pretty creepy mannequin wearing a big
hat that's essentially dressed like the
original version of the Invisible Man
from the 1933 movie you know Jack
Griffin whose name was clearly the
inspiration for Adrian Griffin wait what
was that
that transition looks unbelievably close
to one of the transitions I created for
my other series horror history not to
mention that subscribe animation looking
a little too familiar these guys are
really doing their homework on me I mean
you think they'd at least changed the
order of some of these so it looks a
little bit less completely blatant that
they ripped my video point four-point
sentence for sentence image for image Oh
oh but look it's okay look look they put
their number graphic in the top-left
rather than the bottom right it's okay
guys it's all good
copyright infringement avoided in the
meantime there were some more
contemporary references as well the
blanket pulling scene pays homage to the
conjurer and when Cecilia spreads coffee
beans all over the floor to try to catch
the invisible man's footsteps it's very
reminiscent of paranormal activity where
the character Katie spreads flour on the
floor to try to record the invisible
entities footsteps but there were also
plenty of homages two other popular
horror films the conjuring franchise
also features characters haunted by
forces and there are some particularly
terrifying moments that take place in
bedrooms in the Invisible Man there's a
scene where Cecilia's blanket is pulled
which is very reminiscent of moments
we've seen in the conjuring and the
conjuring - wrong that doesn't happen in
the conjuring - of course the one
teeny-tiny moment you say something
differently than what I said you're just
wrong about it continue and this isn't
the only horror movie reference we
spotted hold on pause it again what do
you mean we spotted hold you mean we
another spooky flick featuring haunted
characters is paranormal activity during
the first movie we saw Katie trying to
track down the spectral being haunting
her home by laying the flower out on the
floor are you kidding me right now I
pointed out similarities - to existing
horror movies and you bring up the exact
same - and then it just in case it
wasn't clear that you're criminals you
follow it up with this I think that the
director of the Invisible Man
Leigh Whannell put in these connections
because he's friends with James Wan who
directed the conjuring and Oren Peli who
directed Paranormal Activity in fact
when ELLs directorial debut was
insidious chapter 3 excellent movie and
that film was produced by one and Pele
the fact that director Leigh Whannell
included nods to the conjuring and
Paranormal Activity definitely were not
coincidences it turns out that 1l knows
Oren Peli
the director of paranormal activity as
well as James Wan who directed the
conjuring Leigh Whannell directorial
debut was on the film insidious chapter
3 and do you want to guess the names of
two of the producers on that movie and
this is where you really [ __ ] up
screen rants because references to other
Invisible Man movies could have been
discovered by anyone who's seen the
movies but this proves beyond any
reasonable doubt that there's no way you
made your video without watching my
video because there are plenty of movies
where people or objects get rocked by an
invisible entity so much so that I even
made up a term for it on my channel we
call it Airy eating
my brain related to these moments in the
conjuring and Paranormal Activity
because I was a teenager from 2007 to
2013 when the trend of paranormal horror
movies was at its peak and I was there
to take those movies in it's not like
there's an interview with the director
where he cites these moments as
influences and we both saw the article
because no such interview exists this is
literally just my interpretation my
theory about why he might have gotten
the ideas that he had because of the
people that he was around at the time
she ends up in the hospital she ends up
in the hospital and in the hallway
there's another patient who's completely
wrapped in bandages the person is so
coated in bandages that they look like
the Invisible Man where he hides his
invisibility by entirely wrapping
himself up in bandages it kind of seems
like they should be in a private ward
but I'm a youtuber not a doctor well
maybe you need to try something else
because I don't think the whole YouTube
thing is really working out for you let
me break down that word for you the U in
YouTube is derived from the word you not
me
cz the world what looks like you've also
ripped off many times in the past
not John solo you've been ripping off in
an unspeakably egregious manner not this
guy on reddit who's Marvel theories you
stole with no permission and no credit
after rejecting his application for a
job you means you yourself if you want
to reap the benefits of hard work you
need to be the one to put in that work
she steals the invisibility suit for
herself because I guess these things
have really good battery life and in
doing so seems to set up the sequel of
the Invisible Woman
she pocketed the invisible suit she used
to stop Ian the scene definitely seemed
as though it was setting up the
Invisible Woman you know what though I'm
a pretty reasonable guy maybe they're
huge well-funded team of writers was
just in a crunch and needed to hit a
deadline maybe they didn't have time to
make something original and we're scared
of the punishment that comes with
falling behind maybe this is just a
product of a bad work environment not
malicious intent they even have an
ethics policy on their website
unless assets are news come from
official studio sources or their PR
affiliates we always provide a link
credit to the original sources we
believe it is our responsibility to
contribute to the online publishing
ecosystem and best journalism practices
so obviously there's just been some kind
of mistake here I decide to send them a
private email and get this whole thing
sorted out hello screen rats I've been
notified that you have repackaged
my analysis of the Invisible Man and
uploaded it as your own video upon
reviewing the content I feel cheated
because Screen Rant is a much bigger
channel taking advantage of my hard work
I'd like to resolve the issue amicably
so I ask that you please give me credit
above the fold in the description with a
link to my channel in the future please
give credit when using my work
apparently this freaked them out a
little bit and with plagiarism like this
it's not hard to imagine why Leigh
Whannell is from Australia so I don't
know how familiar he would be with the
Long Island emo scene but one thing he's
probably familiar with is aquatic life
because Australia is regarded as one of
the world's top scuba destinations
I noticed later in the movie that Sydney
has a jellyfish shirt and that got me
thinking again about Cecilia calling
Adrienne's brother a jellyfish now in
Australia there's a creature known is
that you're a kanji jellyfish and
they're considered dangerous because
they're venomous and they can make
themselves invisible or at least very
close to invisible not only are
jellyfish quite literally spineless but
they're also at least semi-transparent
this was an interesting hint to the fact
that Tom would later end up wearing the
suit and let's not forget that director
Leigh Whannell is from Australia where
the jellyfish and most other animals
can't be incredibly dangerous well I
guess jellyfish aren't the only
creatures that are spineless because
after reading my little email they sent
it on to their parent company and even
bigger firm called vomit gotta let mommy
and daddy take care of the big bad
youtuber I guess but they couldn't even
make this right because instead of just
putting a little blurb in the
description like I asked they just
flat-out denied it they claimed to take
ethics seriously but if they had watched
even a minute of these two videos they
would know that their team of writers
ripped me off
I know it you know it Screen Rant knows
it Valmet knows it your own audience is
even calling you out on it what screen
rants doesn't care because they know
full well that they have a team of
expensive lawyers and I have not enough
money and not enough time or care to
bother pursuing this when I'd rather be
doing something creative or playing
rocket league or trying to figure out
where the key get paper towels when the
whole damn paper towel aisle is empty
and there's nothing online because
that's what these companies do they use
their money they use their resources and
they bully whoever they can afford to
boy but there are clues like Cecelia
painting over her webcam but there were
definitely some hints pointing to it
early on one notable detail was the fact
that Cecilia obscured the built-in
webcam on her computer but the irony
does not end there
oh no because as I mentioned earlier
Screen Rant also has a website where
their favorite thing to do is report on
the acts of plagiarism by other
companies
this is [ __ ] hilarious so if anyone
wants to report on this feel free I'll
grant you what I probably would have
granted screen rent if they had asked
you have my permission to use this video
and one more note on those mechanical
sounds that she hears the Invisible Man
doesn't really have a signature sound
like some of the other classic Universal
Monsters I mean you can't have him growl
like the wolf man or hiss like Dracula
because that would be ridiculous so it's
cool how they found a sound that fits
the sci-fi of reimagining of the story
and also is still really creepy The
Invisible Man is a classic horror
villain but he struggles to be as
recognizable as some other antagonists
unlike the moan of Frankenstein's
monster or the howl of the wolf man this
version of the Invisible Man is
associated with the mechanical kind of
sale so in a way this Invisible Man does
have a signature sale and it ties into
the technology that makes him so creepy
well why did you even steal that that
was just a side note that I said I
didn't even count that as one of my
things you missed you're just making a
fool of yourself now strain rant but
sadly I don't think Screen Rant is the
only company guilty of ripping off
youtubers it's kind of a disturbing
trend just this week I saw a video by
gaming documentary and slugs we had his
most popular video ripped off a year
later by the score eSports by the look
of things it was the same kind of deal
they just take the script reword certain
things remove any semblance of
personality add something that makes you
look like a dummy and publish it acting
like it's your creation if it doesn't
seem like a huge deal just try to
remember that for independent youtube
creators like me john solo slush and
many others this is our job this is our
livelihood I'm a baker selling cakes in
a town of four hundred thousand and
Screen Rant is taking my cakes slapping
on a different colored frosting and
selling them in my town and 17 others
like I said I think I'm being reasonable
to ask that they say something along the
lines of cz swales made a video where he
talks about how these scenes are similar
to see and directed by Oren Peli and
James Wan if you want to see that
there's a link in the description that's
the other thing about these channels
like why do they always sound like
they're constantly saying the same
run-on sentence hey and that goes for
you people putting stuff from my videos
on IMDB - I saw one the other day where
I accidentally said the words
hydrochloric acid in my video when it
should have been
fluoric acid and someone just kind of
transcribed all my points into trivia
bits on IMDB and they wrote hydrochloric
like I didn't even bother to check if it
was correct
anyway I'll put the contact email and
Twitter information for screen rant if
anyone wants to let them know how you
feel about this I think I said it best
in my video about the Invisible Man when
I compared the character Adrienne's
practices to the lyrics sung by Long
Island email band brand-new everyone's
caught on to everything you do I'll see
you in the next one assuming we both
survive
[Music]